[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle année dans Parlement
Hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité au Parlement
et pour cette première de l'année nous
accueillons Erwan balanan bonjour vous
êtes député MoDem du finisterè merci
d'être avec nous pour commenter cette
semaine de reprise au Parlement et on
parlera du baptême du feu pour Gabriel
tal cette semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale première question d'actualité
pour le nouveau Premier ministre à la
tête d'un gouvernement marqué à droite
et puis on reviendra sur les annonces
d'Emmanuel Macron mardi soir lors de sa
conférence de presse le président de la
République a annoncé une batterie de
mesures pour réussir je cite le
réarmement civique de la France ce qui
n'a pas convaincu les oppositions et
puis l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale le ministre de la
Justice Éric Dupont Moretti a été
auditionné sur le projet de loi qui vise
à inscrire dans la Constitution la
liberté des femmes de recourir à l'IVG
Emmanuel Macron espère une adoption du
texte par le Parlement en mars prochain
les parlementaires seront alors réunis
en congrès à
versaill c'était donc la première séance
de question au gouvernement pour Gabriel
hatal nouveau Premier ministre pas de
coup d'éclat particulier ni de clash
mais plusieurs moments forts lors de ces
QAG que l'on va revoir avec Stéphanie
despierr à l'Assemblée pour le plus
jeune premier ministre de la 5e
République tout commence par une
à 34 ans devant les députés de son camp
gabrielal vient d'endosser le costume de
chef de la majorité présidentielle 4 He
plus tard première séance de question
gouvernement il cherche à imposer sa
marque oui des Français traverse de très
grandes difficultés oui il y a des
Français qui doutent il y a des Français
qui souffrent il y a des Français en
colère des Français qui n'y croi plus et
je le dis je ne tomberai jamais dans le
fatalisme consistant pens que les
problèmes des Français ne peuvent pas
être réglés dans l'attente d'une
nouvelle vague de nomination les bands
des ministres sont en parti vide son
gouvernement n'est pas encore complet
gabrielal est déjà la cible de la gauche
ceci n'est pas un REM c'est un
effondrement artisan du malheur des
Français depuis bientôt 7 ans puis
Premier ministre depuis 7 jours d'un
gouvernement que vous n'avez pas choisi
vous étiez minoritaire en 2023 vous
serez minoritaire en 2024 je regarde pas
d'où les gens viennent je regarde où ils
veulent aller je ne regarde pas les gens
pour ceux qu'ils sont mais pour ce
qu'ils font vous vous présentez devant
nous avec un gouvernement qui fait
figure d'aveux fin du en même temps et
cohabitation assumée avec la droite dure
après la préférence nationale voici la
préférence Sarkozi j'assume totalement
s'il vous plaît je préfère travailler
avec Rachid adati Catherine vaterin
comme moi qu'avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
comme vous voilà jeudi Gabriel a réuni
ses ministres pour préparer son discours
de politique générale il a décidé de
prendre son temps ce sera le 30 janvier
soit 3 semaines après sa nomination mais
le nouveau locataire de Matignon ne veut
prendre aucun risque il ne se soumettra
pas au vote de confiance de l'Assemblée
nationale Erwan banan vous avez observé
les premiers cas les premiers pas de
Gabriel hatal comme premier ministre
est-ce que ça fait du bien d'avoir un
profil
politique madame borne était aussi
politique mais dans un autre style euh
c'est sûr que Gabriel Atal a une
facilité à c'est un tribin en réalité
c'est un tribin moderne jeune avec une
aisance dans dans dans le dans le combat
politique et dans le l'ajoute politique
et je pense oui que ça ça peut être un
vrai atout parce qu'on on a besoin en
réalité de d'expliquer un certain nombre
de choses et surtout expliquer les
bonnes choses qu'on a faites depuis 6
ans moi je suis frappé par euh tout un
tas de mesures qui ont été qui nous qui
ont préservé les Français durant cette
période de covid durant cette période de
de boucliers tarifairire toutes les
réformes que nous avons mis en place qui
ont permis à la France de de d'avoir un
taux de chômage historiquement bas tout
ça il faut qu'on le rappelle et c'est
vrai que Gabriel Attal a cette pugnacité
à cette combativité qui sans doute nous
fera du bien et pourtant sa nomination
ne va pas changer la donne à l'Assemblée
nationale car Gabriel Atal n'aura
toujours pas de majorité absolue dans
l'hémicycle non ça changera pas la don
la donne d'un point de vue on va dire
numéraire d'un point de vue de de de des
équilibres des forces maintenant Gabriel
Atal a l'immense avantage d'avoir été un
parlementaire qui qui assiégé Elisabeth
borne était parlementaire mais elle
n'avait pas elle n'avait pas eu la
grande chance de de de
siéger à l'Assemblée donc il connaî les
rouages il connaî comment on peut
négocier et et surtout comment on peut
emporter certaines majorités mais je
rappelle quand même il faut rappeler au
Françis que sur la séquence qui vient de
se passer des 18 mois de depuis
l'élection on a passé plus de 50 textes
21 textes à l'unanimité donc c'est
parfaitement possible d'avoir des des
des majorités de projet c'était un des
c'était une des ambitions de de de
Madame borne et en réalité elle a réussi
on retient que les 493 mais les 493
c'est juste quatre textes budgétaires et
un texte budgétaire assez particulierers
qui étaient les retraites les autres
textes sont tous passés 1493 alors
revenons sur la composition politique du
gouvernement puisque Gabriel hatal a
nommé un gouvernement plutôt marqué à
droite Rachida Dati Catherine Vautrin
sans oubli Bruno Lemire et Damana votre
collègue du MoDem Jean-Louis bourlange
aurait préféré dit-il que le modem
soutienne ce gouvernement dominé par
d'anciens sarkozistes mais sans y
participer est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec lui pas enfin enfin c'était une
option mais la la réalité on a
effectivement deux personnalités
nouvelles qui rentrent re gouvernement
je rappelle que il y a qu'une de ces
deux personnalités qui vient deslr
madame vautterin a depuis longtemps
quitté les LR et de et de la même façon
que ce que vous dites marqué à droite
sont des gens qui sont déjà dans la
Renaissance depuis un moment monsieur
darmana sa carte à Renaissance Monsieur
le Maire aussiite viennent de
droiteement ils viennent de droite il y
a aussi des gens dans cet hémicycle qui
viennent de gauche bon donc alors pour
répondre à votre question concrètement
sur Jean-Louis bourlange Jean-Louis
bourlange il pose une question avec sa
grande expérience c'est
quel va être le programme politique et
c'est ça que nous attendons
effectivement avec impatience parce que
pour l'instant il y a un seul ministre
modem dans ces ministères de plein
exercice avec beaucoup de ministres qui
sont issus de la droite Katia l'a dit le
compte n'y est pas pour le modem pour
l'instant pour être représenté dans dans
cet exécutif moi j'aime pas parler de
compte parce que ça fait un peu
apothicaaire et et et c'est pas comme ça
qu'on mais vous souhaitez plutôt un
rééquilibr souhaite un rééquilibrage ma
collègue Luquet porte-parole du groupe
avec moi on a parlé de rééquilibrage
audaux
pour faire un écho à l'audace de d'avoir
un premier ministre si jeune donc oui il
faut rééquilibrer il faut rééquilibrer
ne serait-ce que pour être en capacité à
à justement aller chercher des majorités
parfois avec les socio-démocrates et
avec les écologistes je suis sûr que sur
certains sujets on doit pouvoir y
arriver en tout cas moi c'est mon
souhait alors à peine le gouvernement
nommé Amélie oua Castera la minist s'est
retrouvé empétré dans une polémique sur
la scolarisation de ses enfants dans le
privé est-ce que erouan balanan pour
vous une telle polémique avec une telle
polémique celle qui est la ministre de
l'école peut encore être légitime alors
deux choses déjà euh moi je je je
souhaite qu'on arrête cette chasse aux
sorcières à chaque fois sur les les
choix qui sont des choix personnels de
famille bon euh c'est
c'est dernière nouvelle l'école libre en
France privé n'est pas hors la loi donc
un ministre peut faire ce choix et
parfois on a vu que des euh pour fendeur
de ces systèmes mettaient aussi leurs
enfants dans des écoles privées donc
arrêtons la chasse aux sorcières c'est
le premier point après il y a un
deuxième point il y a eu une maladresse
une très grosse maladresse parl de
mensonge certains parlent de mensonge
sur les justifications pour lesquelles
elle a retiré ses enfants du ça soit un
mensonge c'est justement par sincérité
et par envie de bien faire d'avoir un
peu réinventé ce qu'elle y ce qui était
un souvenir elle l'a dit elle s'en est
excusé maintenant est-ce que on va lui
en vouloir et est-ce que lui en vouloir
fera avancer la cause de l'éducation
nationale qui est pour moi un des axes
principals de ce de de cette séquence
que nous devons avoir donc faisons-lui
confiance et moi je le dis on lui fait
confiance et je dis aussi que lui faire
un procès sans arrêt c'est pas ça qui va
faire avancer la cause de l'éducation
nationale mais vous pensez pas qu'il ris
d' avoir un dialogue de Sour avec tous
les personnels de l'Éducation nationale
dont on sait qu'ils sont un peu remontés
non parce que son équipe va être
complété je pense qu'elle aura des
secrétaires d'État ou des ministres
délégués sur sur les Surel sur les
sujets et et et et voilà il y a pas de
raison que on avance pas sur ces
questions là sachant qu'en plus on a un
ministre premier un Premier ministre qui
est maintenant bien imprégné de ces
sujets et qui a une volonté forte autour
de l'éducation nationale qui je le redis
ça doit être un des un des points
saillants de cette séquence et on devra
retenir qu'on a fait beaucoup pour
l'éducation nationale moi c'est un de
mes souits et il y a une échance
importante pour le Premier ministre
Gabriel Atal c'est le 30 janvier c'est
la date de son discours de tique
générale est-ce que ce discours d'abord
il sert vraiment à quelque chose car on
va le voir Emmanuel Macron a déjà parlé
a déjà dessiné la suite du quinquena
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de ce
discours de politique générale ah ben
non c'est pas la même chose le discours
du Président c'est un discours un peu
plus général et on n pas rentré j'ai
envie de dire dans le moteur on n pas
ouvert le capot et on n pas commencé à
faire la mécanique des décisions qu'on
doit prendre pour pour les temps qui
viennent donc moi j'attends
effectivement plusieurs choses déjà un
discours de politique général c'est
aussi une méthode quelle méthode Gabriel
Atal va va mettre en place comment
va-t-il gouverner ça c'est quelque chose
qui qu'ut on a une attente là-dessus
ensuite il y a la déclinaison d'un
certain nombre de de de sujet sur des
sujets importants pour la vie des
Français le logement on en parlera
peut-être la santé évidemment
l'éducation nationale et puis un sujet
important qui est qui presque englobe
tout qui est un peu la mer des batailles
c'est aussi la transition écologique et
notre position dans le monde sur la
méthode il veut aller vite gouverner par
circulaire par décret vous craignez
qu'il contourne le Parlement non il
pourra pas contourner on est le
Parlement le le Parlement dans notre
pays est difficilement contournable
parce que ça fait c'est un c'est c'est
le cœur battant de la politique et de la
démocratie donc c'est il pourra pas
contourner le gouvernement et je sais
qu'il n'a pas l'envie de le Parlement
pardon il a pas l'envie de le faire tout
simplement parce que il est
parlementaire et il est parlementaire
dans l'âme en tout cas n'a pas demandé
de vote de confiance à l'issue de sa
déclaration de politique générale vous
le regrettez il manque de courage non il
manque pas de courage les les les règles
mathématiques de cette répartition sont
là la conf confiance il ne l'aura pas ça
ne sert à rien de d'aller la la chercher
c'est comme ça on est en on est en
majorité relative donacte c'est pas le
premier ministre qui l'est et ça sera
certainement pas le premier ministre ça
pas le dernier à être en majorité
relative dans ce pays en tout cas dans
ce modèle institutionnel alors on le
disait le président de la République a
tenu cette semaine une grande conférence
de presse pour dessiner la suite de son
quinquena beaucoup d'annonces sur
l'école sur la famille pour opérer ce
qu'il appelle un réarmement civique et
démographique de la France une vision
qui n'a pas plu à la gauche du Sénat
Marion
dalpèche sans surprise au Sénat les
oppositions ne ressortent pas convaincu
par la prestation du chef de l'État jugé
loin des préoccupations des Français par
le sénateur communiste Yann brossa j'ai
vu un un long monologue pénible d'un
président de la République arrogant qui
ne répond en rien au problèmes des
Français en matière de pouvoir d'achat
de bas salaire de difficultés de la vie
quotidienne et donc je l'ai surtout
trouvé à côté de la place au regard de
de ces préoccupations là même son de
cloche pour le chef de fil des
socialistes au Sénat Patrick hanner d'
voir dans la conférence de presse
d'Emmanuel Macron un exercice assumé
d'autosatisfaction le président Macron
hier m'a
rassuré notre pays va bien l'ascenseur
sociale fonctionne et nos services
publics ont les moyens de remplir leur
mission j'ai sans doute été distrait car
pour moi la réalité était toute autre
dans ma réalité l'école publique est
fragilisée par des professeur non
remplacé desabusés l'hôpital public
s'effondre dans ma réalité la France
compte désormais près de 5 millions de
pauvres et la classe moyenne a de plus
en plus de mal à joindre les debouts
parmi la longue liste d'annonces faite
par le chef de l'État l'expérimentation
de l'uniforme à l'école un nouveau congé
de naissance un plan contre
l'infertilité ou encore le doublement de
l'enseignement civique des mesures
saluées par le sénateur François patria
soutient d'Emmanuel Macron je crois que
ce qu'a voulu dire le Président c'est
qu' voulait les faire des républicains
et faire des républicains c'est le rôle
de la famille c'est le rôle de l'école
c'est le rôle de l'entreprise c'est le
rôle de l'environnement général c'est le
rôle de la vie quotidienne je pense
qu'il était bon de de le rappeler non
pas de façon paternaliste comme je l'ai
entendu pas ici ou là mais de rappeler
que simplement dans son mode de vie dans
son respect vis-à-vis des autres on a
besoin aujourd'hui de redresser la barre
parce que ce n'est pas le cas voilà pour
ces réaction de sénateur à la conférence
de presse d'Emmanuel Macron le président
de la République qui a centré ses
annonces sur l'école la famille sur
l'ordre sur l'autorité pour je cite que
la France reste la France il a
d'ailleurs repris un slogan de campagne
d'éc Zemour est-ce que Erwan balanan ce
discours conservateur il correspond à
vos valeurs on est un peu loin des des
valeurs du MoDem quand même alors oui
enfin si si vous le prenez comme ça et
et à votre lecture et à la lecture d'un
certain nombre de de d'observateurs mais
moi j'ai un peu approfondi et et j'ai
posé des questions à à certaines
personnes que que je connais qui sont
politisé sans sans être dans la
mécanique mais je suis désolé euh ils
m'ont dit mais en quoi euh la famille
c'est nécessairement une valeur de
droite en quoi l'école l'école c'est une
valeur de gauche euh quand on dit que il
va falloir réarmer l'école alors je le
dis moi j'aime pas cette j'aime pas
cette expression elle est guerrière je
préférerais qu'on dise réenchanter
l'école réenchanter le pays réenchanter
le le le le contrat républicain et et je
dirais plutôt le réenchantement que le
réarmement en quoi ce cette cette idée
làà serait une idée de droite je je
j'avoue que les bras m tombent en
réalité quand vous dites on va faire en
sorte de redonner du travail aux gens de
d'avancer sur la question salaire parce
que c'est c'est des choses qui ont été
dites sur l'école dire que on va donner
la chance à tout le monde d'acquérir les
savoirs fondamentaux qui permettent de
réussir dans la vie en quoi cela est de
droite pas plus que de gauche d'ailleurs
al justement l'école c'est un sujet que
vous connaissez bien Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé une refondte totale de
l'instruction civique et notamment
l'expérimentation de la tenue unique
dans une centaine d'établissement est-ce
que pour vous c'est vraiment ce type
d'annonce ces mesures là qui peuvent
permettre de refonder l'école et de
résoudre les problème actuel de l'école
publique vous savez comment fonctionne
notre monde médiatique et notre monde
avec les réseaux sociaux il y a besoin
d'avoir des points d'accroche et moi
effectivement je ne pense pas que c'est
bien de faire l'expérimentation c'est
bien
d'essayer l'uniforme voilà pourquoi pas
testons mais je suis à peu près enfin
j'ai la conviction que c'est pas ça qui
va sauver l'école nécessairement ce qui
va sauver l'école c'est c'est aussi une
prise en compte de ce sujet par toute la
société de se dire l'école c'est
prioritaire et
réenchanter la la vie scolaire
réenchanter la la réussite parce que
c'est ça aussi l'école c'est de réussir
il y a des enfants qui sont issus de
milieu très populaire et qui par le
parcours de l'école qu'elle soit publque
ou privée réussissent des parcours
merveilleux et c'est ça qu'il faut
remontrer et on a plein d'exemples moi
j'ai des exemples dans les
collaborateurs que l'on croise parfois à
l'assemblée des gens qui ont des des
diplômes très élevés j'ai eu une
collaboratrice qui a commencé son
parcours par un beep dans une dans une
elle avait été mise dans elle était
scolarisée dans un endroit difficile et
on l'avait un peu assigné à résidence
elle s'est battu elle a réussi par
l'école à
devenir attaché parlementaire puis
membre d'un cabinet c'est des c'est des
exemples comme ça qu'il faut promouvoir
et c'est ça le réenchantement il me
semble qu'on doit qu'on doit qu'on doit
essayer de de promouvoir alors dans
cette conférence de presse le président
de la République qui a aussi confirmé la
baisse d'impôt de 2 milliards d'euros
pour les classes moyennes en 2025 contte
tenu de l'état de nos finances publiques
est-ce que c'est le moment d'annoncer
des baisses de recettes pour l'État ça
veut pas dire nécessairement des baisses
de recettes ou alors comment on les
finance c'est c'est ce c'est ce que nous
au modem on on on essayie de de pousser
depuis un moment c'est une répartition
plus juste et peut-être faire contribuer
des classes qui sont supérieures qui qui
aujourd'hui peuvent contribuer donc un
impôt sur les plus riches c'est ça qui
manque un impôt sur les plus riches pas
nécessairement j'aime pas ce terme sur
les plus riches en tout cas ceux qui ont
parce que dès qu'on s'amuse à définir la
richesse vous savez il y en a qui se
sont pris lesed les pieds dans le tapis
sur cette histoire donc non mais mieux
répartir trouver des des recettes
nouvelles nous on avait proposé des
choses autour des de la des taxation des
super qui n' jamais été retenu ça n'a
pas été retenu mais vous savez on est
généralement pugnas et on est
généralement déterminé pourra avancer
effectivement je pense que les classes
moyennes aujourd'hui euh euh méritent
d'avoir leurs impôts qui baissent ils
sont toujours à la limite entre ceux qui
ont des aides et ceux qui n'ont pas
d'aide et ils se retrouvent dans des
situations parfois difficiles alors
qu'ils travaillent et qu'ils ont des
familles à nourrir et que il y a parfois
un sentiment d'injustice qui qui qui
n'est vous savez il y a pas de grande
démocratie sans grande sans un sans sans
des classes moyenne c'est
sociologiquement historiquement ça
n'existe pas donc on a besoin d'une
classe moyenne et surtout on a besoin
d'une classe moyenne qui a la conviction
que pour ses enfants si tout le monde
travaille s'il y a s'il y a une volonté
de réussir les la situation s'améliorera
dans dans la famille et et voilà c'est
tout simplement ça qu'il faut faire et
je crois que la répartition de la de
l'effort peut-être pe peut-êtreevu à la
marge certainement mais peut-êtreevu on
avait par exemple proposé plus de de
tranches d'impôt c'est quelque chose qui
permet de de lisser la la répartition
également le président a aussi été
interrogé sur la loi immigration il a
défendu la suppression de certaines
prestations sociales pour les étrangers
pendant un délis hein c'est une mesure
qui avait été ajoutée à ce texte par les
républicains je rappelle que Erwan
balanan vous avez voté contre ce projet
de loi immigration est-ce que vous
espérez qu'il soit fortement censuré la
semaine prochaine par le Conseil
constitutionnel et si oui sur quel point
moi j'ai j'ai j'avais fait une liste d'à
peu près 30 dispositifs qui pourrai être
censurés donc on va voir ça fait
beaucoup ça fait beaucoup ça fait
beaucoup mais le texte est très est très
dense aussi donc c'est pas non plus
étonnant euh oui moi j'espère qu'un
certain nombre de choses seront
censurées euh c'est c'est c'est un texte
c'est pas le texte qu'on voulait je
crois que tout le monde est conscient
dans la majorité que c'était pas le
texte que
initial on avait un bon texte au départ
et c'est bien dommage qu'il y ait eu
cette séquence et c'estes coup
politiques de la gauche et de l'extrême
droite qui qui amène à cette à ce
mauvais texte qui ne sert àen rien en
l'état actuel des choses donc il va être
toqué et il y a peut-être des
dispositifs sur lequel on va être obligé
de revenir à un moment ou un autre parce
que par exemple l'article 4 Beast donc
l'article de régularisation qui sortit
de la CMP nous on le dit il est papier
dans voilà dans les métiers en
sentention tel qu'il a été écrit il est
ni fait ni à faire donc c'est peut-être
des sujets sur lequel il faudra revenir
peut-être par voie réglementaire
d'ailleurs alors une question sur un
dernier point Emmanuel Macron veut
réarmer l'école un terme que vous
n'aimez pas vous préférez pr celui de
réenchantement il veut aussi un
réarmement démographique il dit et
inciter les Français à faire des enfants
à faire plus d'enfants est-ce que les
les enfants sont une arme est-ce que ça
vous choque ce terme de réarmement
démographique il a il a pris ce terme
parce que c'est un terme qu'il a repris
pour le réarmement civique pour le voilà
bon c'est vrai que c'est pas comment
vous comprenez
cette c'est pas pour faire des enfants
des une arme mais tout simplement notre
modèle social fonctionne sur un modèle
démographique et à partir du moment où
ce modèle démographique ne tient plus le
modèle social ne tient plus c'est c'est
c'est tout simple hein c'est de
l'économie niveau 1 donc et on a un
problème pour les retraites et on a un
problème pour les retraites mais pas que
pour les retraites pour le financement
de notre modèle social dans son ensemble
donc oui voilà pendant très longtemps on
a eu un taux de fertilité qui permettait
le renouvellement aujourd'hui on est
comme beaucoup de pays en Europe sans ce
taux de renouvellement il va falloir
peut-être avoir des politiques
familiales mais avoir des politiques
familiales c'est pas retomber dans les
vieilles politiques familiales un peu
par terre l'un list d'un autre temps
aider les femmes à avoir des enfants
c'est aider les couples à avoir des
enfants et surtout aider les femmes tout
au long de leur carrière pour que elles
ne soient pas comment dire les grandes
perdantes de cette politique nataliste
et là-dessus moi je serais très vigilant
vous savez le la différence de
patrimoine créé par une femme et un
homme sur l'ensemble d'une carrière la
moyenne c'est 500000 € 500000 EUR une
très belle maison dans nos provinces et
en Bretagne donc c'est un vrai sujet
alors on va revenir à l'Assemblée
nationale Erwan bananon puisque le
projet de loi constitutionnel destiné à
graver l'IVG dans la Constitution a été
adopté en commission des lois le texte
sera examiné le 24 janvier en séance
publique il reviendra au Sénat en
février avant d'être soumis
éventuellement au congrès de députés et
sénateurs c'est ce que souhaite Emmanuel
Macron Éric Dupont moréti qui porte le
texte est très optimiste écoutez on a un
grand texte de liberté c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on peut tous ensemble euh
préparer porter voter en ce qui vous
concerne un texte de liberté alors soit
on choisit de chipoter mais c'est pas ce
que j'ai entendu aujourd'hui
soit on consacre ce texte on va
l'inscrire dans la dans la Constitution
dans notre Constitution et ce sera oui
le Conseil d'État a cru utile de
rappeler la première fois qu'un pays
inscrit dans sa constitution cette
liberté
euh si j'étais familier je vous dirais
ça de la gueule si je le suis moins je
peux vous dire ça quand même beaucoup
d'allure Erwan Balanant vous êtes
optimiste selon vous le Parlement va
adopter cette inscription de livivg dans
la Constitution ah ben je l'espère oui
j'espère qu'on va avoir cette cette
avancée qui est une avancée qui est ce
que j'ai expliqué moi en commission
c'est une sorte défit cliquet
c'est-à-dire que on dit notre pays dit
on ne reviendra jamais en arrière sur ce
sujet on l'inscrit dans la plus dans le
plus haut des textes dans notre
Constitution mais personne ne veut
revenir en arrière sur l'IVG personne ne
ve j'ai envie de vous dire mon œil mon
œil quand on aentendu les débats quand
on voit certains amendements portés par
certaines familles politiques en France
et je pense au LR et au rassemblement
national mon œil il y a des gens qui
veulent revenir en arrière il y a des
gens qui quand ils seront au pouvoir
reviendront peut-être en arrière de
certains députés LR ça pourrait oui
parfaitement don pas seulement du
rassemblement national pas seulement du
rassemblement national donc mettons cet
effet de cliquet le texte tel qu'il a
été écrit qui est le le fruit d'un d'un
consensus entre l'écriture qui était
d'ailleurs avec un peu de fierté je le
dis mon écriture à l'Assemblée nationale
le 22 novembre 2022 lors du texte adopté
voilà et ensuite le Sénat qui a une
vision un petit peu différente et il y a
un consensus qui s'est fait et
maintenant il faut aller jusqu'au bout
et il faut qu'on ait les débats parce
que ça sera des beaux débats et des
débats qui marqueront aussi l'histoire
politique de notre pays mais justement
vous vous étiez impliqué dans le la
rédaction d'un amendement commun qui
avait permis de de trouver un accord
transpartisan sur le texte initial
présenté par Mathilde Panau de la France
insoumise est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la
formulation telle qu'elle est retenue
vous convient parce que vous vous
souhaitiez non pas reconnaître une
liberté mais reconnaître inscrire dans
la Constitution le droit femes à
recourir à moi je suis satisfait parce
qu'en réalité après discussion avec un
certain nombre de
constitutionnalistes les deux sont ont
la même portée effective et juridique
donc si c'est que un problème sémantique
et de de vocabulaire on va pas on va pas
se se faire des nœuds au cerveau pour ça
par contre en plus ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'écriture telle
qu'elle a été faite sur ce travail de
consensus elle est encore un peu mieux
parce que moi j'avais pas pensé
effectivement à l'article 34 et c'était
dommage parce que l'article 34 de la
Constitution il va être un nouvel alinéa
de l'article 34 de la Constitution et ça
lui donne encore plus de force que là où
on l'avait mis avec un article 66-2 qui
était un peu maladroitement placé juste
après la peine de mort enfin voilà on a
quelque chose qui comme l'a dit 34 c'est
la loi c'est le cœur de la loi oui c'est
la loi c'est la loi et et pour tous ceux
qui peut-être découvrent le droit
constitutionnel que ça soit l'article 1
ou le dernier article de notre
Constitution ils ont toutes tous la même
portée et ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup banan d'avoir été le premier
invité de l'année de Parlement Hebdo
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cette
émission et à la semaine prochaine ciao
ciao
[Musique]